hi during the course of this conference
you've learned lots of cool stuff and I
know it can be overwhelming so before I
even begin with what we're going to
learn today here's what I want you to
remember i'm michelle butter and
everything I'm going to cover will be on
my website you can also go straight to
the example project repo don't feel like
you have to frantically take notes or
remember everything it's all available
for you to copy and paste into your own
project if there's one thing I want to
make sure you remember from today it is
this do less accomplish more so let's
make some cool stuff but not work too
hard today you're gonna learn about how
to use data to help you get a raise I'm
going to discuss my method of collecting
and formatting the data I'm also going
to show you how to build it and deploy
your own tool to track and report the
data using AWS and Python personally I'm
a project-based learner so my goal here
is to demonstrate a new technology and a
practical business skill that way you
can accomplish two things at once you
learn a new technology and have a method
for improving your career because I want
you to do less and accomplish more here
are the different tools I used to make
yet I'll be going to a lot more detail
later but just just so you know what
we'll be covering if none of these words
mean anything to you
great I'll explain it if you're an
expert
please stay anyway but also give me your
email address because I still have lots
of questions now that you know the tech
this is going to be our agenda why did I
choose these tools a definition of all
the terms so we're on the same page what
is this app and how is it going to help
me with raises the data we're going to
collect actually creating the app and
finally the alternatives today tools I
mentioned and future plans for the app
I want to start with why did I choose
these tools to explain why these AWS
services and service apps in general
appeal to me I want to give you a bit of
my background eight years ago I got an
extremely practical degree in 3d
animation luckily for me I had some
experience coding so when a job came up
to work in a tech department at a VFX
company I jumped at it working in
entertainment technology is very
different than other large technology
companies technology is not their
business art is it's just a means to an
end
anything that will get the artists
producing faster or higher quality
images will be used this work cycle is
also not in Sprint's quarters or years
but instead is counted in projects and
film shots my first job was focused on
reducing the company's biggest
expenditure artist time if you were
working on a tool and it was not done
fast enough to actually help on the
project you were contracted to work on
it was useless this taught me to be
practical and put business needs first
not technology if that wasn't my first
job I would definitely suffer more of
the consequences of what I like to call
the engineer mindset having an engineer
mindset means never being able to turn
off the part of your brain that says I
can tackle any problem even if I don't
have any expertise or background on it
how many of you have been waiting in a
store or a vet and thought to yourself
about how an app could make this go
better I don't want to tell you how many
grocery store apps I've envisioned in
line I've never worked on logistics but
because I can't turn it off I want to
fix the issue the problem-solving
mindset is generally a positive trait
but can lead to some unintended
consequences let's talk about a common
scenario Engineers face you're given a
work assignment your customer wants a
big new feature
you now have two choices you could
either start coding right away or spend
a bunch of time researching I know what
I want to do getting code on the page
seems like we'll be faster and a lot
more fun but let's think about this by
not taking advantage of available open
source tools you're saying that you have
better solution that everyone who has
ever had the same problem sure you might
be smarter than one person online or
even two how about a hundred people a
hundred thousand you can never beat that
as an individual of course not every
problem hasn't solved and you might have
to adjust what you find to fit your
specific needs but if you can describe
your need as a general technical issue
100 others probably have already so why
not let the tech community help you so
you can do less and accomplish more
you're probably wondering what does this
have to do with servos X or if you're me
and a few months ago what is a service
that I'll get to that I like to think of
service apps as someone doing work I'm
not interested in so I can focus on
getting great features out for my
clients they're also a great example of
letting a hundred thousand people solve
your problem before I start working
before I started working with service
apps most of my projects met a dead end
at the same place I was great at
designing api's of functions but had no
interest in DevOps so when it came to
actually learning how to deploy my app I
would see about 20 different concepts I
didn't understand and give up it wasn't
that I was incapable it's just not what
excites me so I did not make the time
before I get into the technical details
I'm going to define some terms I know
that you're here because you're
interested in Python but one of the joys
of Python is that the possibilities are
endless the products I make and the
projects you make could be totally
different so let's start with a
you've been waiting for here's a
definition from ATO WS on what a service
APIs serval is computing allows you to
build and run applications and services
without thinking about servers service
applications don't require you to
provision scale and manage any servers
you can build them for nearly any type
of application or back-end service
everything required to run and scale
your application with high availability
is handled for you you know what that
sounds like doing less an account
pushing roar now let's talk about the
app itself what are the basic building
blocks of an application
I'm sure you could debate me on this and
now that you know you can find me on
Twitter definitely will but for the
purposes of this talk I've broken up
into five parts first is the data
storage or some way of having persistent
information it could be anything from a
my sequel database to a text file some
way of taking data and holding on to it
next is the algorithm doing something
with the data do calculations organize
it differently it doesn't matter as long
as you're changing it in some way a
quick aside here if you're not changing
anything you probably don't need to make
this at one of my art teachers used to
say with animation anything you can
imagine you can make but if you could
just film it it's a lot cheaper if you
don't need to change anything don't
build an app after that is the interface
this is some way of running the
algorithm and accessing the data it
could be an API a script or even a
graphical interface next is the home
somewhere to store your apps that is
outside of your computer and finally the
deployment how to get your app to its
home now that we know the different
parts of the app before we get to the
specific tech let's talk about the app
we're going to make the app is called
ROI track
we're going to make an app that tracks
your personal return on investment so
that it performance review time you have
the numbers to make your case I like to
use the business term ROI because
because it puts me in the mindset of am
I making more money for the company that
they are spending on me am i making them
a lot more do they know that and if not
I better tell them so they give me more
money how we do that is with a formula
called success statements the origin of
success statements is from a
communications failure a manager was
given a large team Edgar a year she was
called as the office of the vice
president and asked what she had she
done with the last year while she knew
she had grown her team and implemented
many improvements she did not have the
numbers to back it up to the vice
president it looked like she had hardly
done anything all year when she felt
like she had gone above and beyond this
is when she developed success statements
success statements are a way of
translating your accomplishments into
the language everyone in business can
understand money the content of success
statement should be these three things
it should be a hundred forty characters
or less just like classic Twitter you
should be able to scan through a list of
them like a resume they should be
written at a high level and easy to
comprehend for someone who might not
understand what you do
they should be quantified in money or
time money is the easiest but since
salary can be one of the biggest
corporate costs time can be translated
and to cost savings here's the exact
format of the sentence by having a
consistent format it's easy to read and
keeps you on message I improve this
thing using this method by this
measurable amount here's an example of
one I reduce storage costs by archiving
data saving five dollars monthly
reduced storage costs is improve this
thing by archiving data is this method
and measurable amount is five dollars
monthly here's a second example using
time I reduce the manual testing by
creating automated tests saving 60
minutes weekly reduced manual tests is
improve this thing by creating automated
test is this method and their measurable
amount is 60 minutes weekly now you
might be thinking I've learned this
great communication method thanks
Michelle but why do I need an dad to
track them there are only two examples
but at the end of the year I would have
a hundred I'd have to manually comb
through them figure out which ones to
include by date and calculate the
savings it was a pain that's why I made
our alright tracker earlier I went over
the parts of an application which you'll
see again on the left on the right
you'll see the tools I use for each
DynamoDB is the data storage it's a non
relational database it's more like a
dumping ground for data instead of a
well organized sequel database however
it's easy to set up and use so great for
small apps lambda holds the algorithm
this is the meat of the serverless app a
lambda is simply a function that's it if
you've written a script or a tool before
you can transfer that into a lambda API
gateway is the interface it handlers it
handles the routing views and schema
validation of a traditional web
framework s3 is the home s3 is a
flexible storage area and connects
easily with other parts there are many
ways to deploy a service app for this
one I found Sam to be the right fit Sam
used a yeah Motel template to tell AWS
these are the services I want to use
please set them up there are simpler
ways to do this such as chalice a Python
library
or more robust such as cloud formation
but for this app I took the middle
ground one final step for actually
making the app I need to know what data
I want to reported what are my goals
here I landed on two things in a given
time period such as the last year I want
to know the total time and money safe I
want to know not just my immediate
impact but over the entire year if I
saved a hundred dollars on a monthly
process that's $1,200 after a year if I
save ten minutes a day that's forty
three hours a year the employee I saved
was making twenty dollars an hour I save
eight hundred sixty dollars that year
these small changes add up so what
information do I need to collect to get
these totals for the total time I
collected these three things for each
innovation the duration in seconds or
how much time I saved when I started
saving the time and how often it
recurred was it daily weekly yearly or
just once for total cost
I collected similar information they set
cost and cents instead of duration in
seconds finally to make sure I gave my
report entirely in money if necessary I
needed to convert time to money for this
I use the number of employees affected
by the innovation and their salary of
course not everyone can get employee
salaries so it's optional now it's time
to create the app while I explain the
different AWS services I use for the app
I'm going to keep referring back to the
Sam template so I'm going to go over
that first what is Sam quoting AWS you
can use Sam to define serverless
applications in simple and clean syntax
Sam is a helper that creates the
CloudFormation template CloudFormation
is a yamo template that you can use to
tell AWS
I want to use all these services and
have them connect in this way if you
want to do something more complex than
what Sam provides such as setting up a
virtual private cloud you can use cloud
formation commands directly in your Sam
template and it will pass it along to
the cloud formation template so just to
be perfectly clear
Sam uses a Yama file that translates
into a more complex cloud formation file
that AWS uses to define the app this is
a top of the yellow file the top two
lines are boilerplate and just a simple
description of your app the next section
is parameters you will need use these
when creating names for the different
parts of the app the stage name
parameter is so that you can have our RI
trackers in different environments like
QA and production and easily see which
ones you're working on by starting all
your components with a service name
parameter they're easy to find when you
have multiple apps the next step is
defining the data storage let's go to
the resources section of a Sam template
resources are components of the app like
the data store and the interface this is
the data store resource DynamoDB is a
non relational database fully managed by
Amazon well I would have preferred that
relational database like my sequel that
takes more work to spin up and manage I
opted for ease of use you can see where
I've started to use the variable names
we set up at top of the Sam template I
also set the ID as the key and set the
throughput low since only I'm using it
when actually accessing the database I
use the Python SDK after I initialize
the client I created a table then I was
able to use the table to get all the
crud components I created an item using
put because there's no dedicated create
in the
SDK it will create the item if it
doesn't already exist then I received
items in two different ways as a single
item but or by running a scan to get all
the items again there should be a small
table so getting all the items shouldn't
be that time-consuming for the update I
use that same put I used before
and finally delete to get rid of all my
steaks all my mistakes now let's talk
about the interface I use API gateway to
define all the views an API gateway and
point can activate other AWS services in
this case I connected it to a lambda
which I'll go over more in the algorithm
section I decided that I needed five
endpoints for this project I always
serve the crud so the posting get on the
plural success successes and then a put
get and delete on success with an ID I
added one more call report to present a
summary of the data in order to define
the endpoints and add features such as
schema validation I used swagger what is
swagger quoting swagger at i/o swagger
allows you to describe the structure of
your api's so that machines can read
them swagger is an open source tool that
AWS supports AWS can read a swagger file
and define the API gateway accordingly I
added a swagger definition directly in
the template you can also use a separate
file here's how that looks
here's a quick look of a single endpoint
but it's I'm sure it's hard to read
let's zoom in on some of the main
features I'll be skipping around where
you'll find all this in the repo with
many examples first defining the
resource of an API gateway again you can
see the variables in the name
next we'll jump to the start of the
swagger definition so you can see where
I added it into the definition body
right under that we set up a validator
called basic that says the validate both
the body and the
rameters since Dino DB is that no sequel
database
it doesn't inherently allow for limiting
the data that can go in it but I wanted
to to keep organized which is why I
added the validation here after that is
the beginning of the paths here's the
initial post here's where it says to
make sure a body is provided and to
validate to validate against the schema
success right over here the definition
of success this success schema and all
the data we want to collected such as
the duration and the start date finally
this section tells AWS to connect it to
the lambda so the endpoint actually does
something now let's talk about the
algorithm lambdas are functions that AWS
runs for you that's it the definition
from Amazon is AWS lambda lets your run
code without provisioning or managing
servers you pay only for the compute
time you use there's no charge your code
is not running pretty neat I won't go
over the land us using the success
endpoints because you saw most of that
code when I went over the dynamo DB SDK
examples instead I'll go over the report
lambda here's what it looks like in the
Sam template I'm going to highlight a
few sections the handler determines
which file to find that function in this
case report lambda I wanted to make sure
it knows how to find that database table
so I pass it along as an environment
variable here's where I length the
lambda back to the API resource that has
that swagger definition we already went
over finally the policies give the
lambda permission to actually access the
database we main I mean a bunch of
functions for the land at a call
remember the totals I want to calculate
it these functions do it all if I name
them right it should be self-explanatory
but you can see the actual code as well
as test with a bunch of examples in the
repo
the only remaining step is to actually
push this to AWS this requires an s3
bucket to store the actual files then
you can use Sam to package and deploy I
created two shell scripts to help with
this and they're included in the repo
whenever you create a new file or add a
new package to your repo you need to run
update built it puts the file in the
right place for Sam to find when you're
ready to actually deploy your stack you
run test deck you can find more
information about how these shell
scripts work and the commands they
contain in the repo readme once that is
successfully pushed you can double-check
everything you made and test to the AWS
web interface you can actually sidestep
the entire Sam process that I went over
and create everything in the web
interface but that's why burdens them
when doing large projects and I also
found lots of tutorials on how to use
the GUI but much less that help with the
Sam syntax so I wanted to make sure if
you want to make a production-ready tool
you don't experience the same
frustrations I did on syntax here's how
your API will look as soon as I had my
basic API I was able to post all the
successes that are included in the repo
test then when I won the report endpoint
I get a summary ready to bring to my
performance review how I saved $130 in
the past couple months there are a bunch
of features I haven't included in here
but you'll want to make sure you do for
a completed web app such as securing
your endpoints it would also be nice if
I could auto generate some cool graphs
on some of these numbers there are also
other companies offering services
similar to Amazon such as Microsoft and
Google I've heard good things but I
haven't tried it myself the concepts are
similar so try it out it's all free on
the developments here and if you could
report back your findings that would be
swell
if you're thinking Michele you just keep
giving
it's more homework and it seems like it
will benefit you you're right
I want this presentation to be your
jumping-off point
and learn cool things that I can use
because as you have to know by now all I
want to do is do less and accomplish
more now I bet you're wondering what
happened to that manager we talked about
earlier how did using success statements
help her career she became a director
and is currently in charge of multiple
departments after she taught her team
members about success statements they
were also able to achieve great things
these include every year 25% of her
employees are promoted at her company
18% of those receiving company Awards
and 25% of those celebrating 15 years
with a company or from her department I
hope this inspires you to build your app
gather your data and impress your boss
this will show all of your hard work and
your bosses will have no other option
but to give you a raise you're welcome
feel free to send me a percentage of
your newly acquired wealth to help
subsidize my crippling Starbucks
addiction anyone who wants to continue
this conversation feel free to reach out
to me on LinkedIn Twitter or one of the
many public slacks and I'm on if there
are not people I might arrange a group
discussion or even open up the project a
contribution like I said I plenty more
to do I know there are probably a few of
you who might not have questions now
both think of some later I love the keep
the conversation going
additionally I appreciate any feedback
on this presentation today as long as
it's positive any questions
we've got about 15 minutes for questions
so I can come around with a roaming mic
if anybody has any questions you can go
ahead and raise your hand
it is using success statements like
these as part of your review with your
boss like leave you to having goals that
are set against some of these saving
time or saving money and does that make
it like hard for future performance
reviews I actually don't think it's
really showed might really affected the
goals I want to have because your goals
are more set by what the business goals
are about a company like what features
they want to have how you want to grow
yourself I think it just shows extra
things you've accomplished throughout
the year let's say you made that new
feature look at what that feature
accomplished for the company for someone
that hasn't tried any app development or
hosting on any of these services is
there a good tutorial that you would
suggest or recommend for kind of getting
started and all these different pieces
that you mentioned and components kind
of the most basic level easiest to get
going yeah AWS itself actually has some
really great tutorials so I'd start with
the meat of it which is the lambda right
so you can say I want to lambda to just
add up a series of numbers or something
like that
so that'll be your example and if you go
to AWS you can start right in the web
interface and say I just want to make my
first lambda in Python and I want to
write a test for it and it'll go through
each step of the way companies like AWS
and Google and Azure they really want
people to use their products so they do
everything they can to document it and
make sure that the people who are doing
development don't have to pay for
anything so I believe it's at like a
million calls when you start having to
pay for things which is nice so are you
besides being the developer of the app
the primary or maybe only user of the
app or do you give it the app to your
manager so they can see what you did
throughout the year so I just made it
just now recently in the last couple of
months because I was like I want to
learn several ACEF so I was doing a
little bit at work and then I was like
what is an app that I've wanted to
deploy for a long time that's like oh I
really want to put
that together so I haven't showed it to
my boss yet but hopefully enjoys the
video this presentation and sees how
much hard work I've been doing
Oh
so what was the hardest part of this to
learn of the most frustrating part like
the worst documentation or whatever
reason yeah it was like the weird errors
that I couldn't figure out how to
explain so there's like a strange error
sometimes where the the API gateway
doesn't connect right to the lambda and
then if you just like refresh the page
it does it's things like that where it's
like you don't learn that until you run
into it and it's hard to Google that so
things like that and and some of the
syntax in the Sam like they're really
basic things like making your first
lambda it's super straightforward
there's lots of examples but when you
want to do something a little more
complex like adding in the swagger or on
my work project not in here I did use a
my sequel database and that was a little
more complicated but there is plenty of
documentation and you can see a lot of
examples especially of the cloud
formation templates where you can try
something out see if it makes it and
just keep going back and forth and just
keep you know I called it test stack not
deploy stack because I kept testing it
over and over and over again I think I
even have like a delete line in there
every time I we tried it so I believe
that answers your question
Oh could you possibly flip it and use it
to track your boss or like you know I'm
saying just well not tracking me like a
stalker kind of like just like get did
yeah yeah I mean I mean you can do
anything like I said it's a non
relational database you could put
anything you want in there if you want
to just use it like every day you're
like okay even in that lunch meeting for
three hours I'm just like put it in
there and then over the course of year
be like how long have they been in lunch
meetings it's like a thousand hours
really what are they up to
are they starting their own company
during lunch like what is happening it's
a little more nefarious I don't know if
you can tell that to anyone that you're
doing that have you ever thought of
tying it to a ticketing system like a
juror to track your you know your data
and be able to present it back there
yeah
that would be great I think to to show
results I think that would be an awesome
there was actually a presentation here
yesterday about hacking JIRA and now
that I know more about that I think
that's an excellent suggestion for a new
feature the first job
I was talking about with that manager we
actually didn't have any sort of
ticketing system it was kind of just
like just do stuff so that was part of
the problem right we weren't tracking
anything in any way so the end of the
year like what did I do now stuff are
there any resources you would suggest
for just learning more about
non-relational databases in general I
would definitely look at dynamo TPS
there's a lot of information on that and
also on [ __ ] most of the time it's not
that useful like that's why I had to say
like a bunch of caveats like I use it
because it was like really easy for this
but anytime you're doing a super large
production project I found that MongoDB
and other non-relational databases
didn't just get frustrating if you're
planning to have a bunch of interrelated
tables but there are definitely use
cases for it and the nice thing is it is
just a WL so if you just want to play
around with things and you don't
actually like maybe I haven't decided
what data I want I just wanna like put
some data in a table I think it's a
great use case and you can go on AWS to
see the dynamodb or look at MongoDB
because those are kind of the big ones
that people are using right now
so that I'm gonna repeat the question
since she didn't have the microphone so
she asked how much I spent on AWS
I spent $0 I click the little button in
the settings it's like please alert me
if I spend any money and I also you know
I looked at between this and doing some
projects that works I did like all the
calculations of like what is actually
gonna cost me money here and most of it
is actual usage and since it's just me
using it and not like an app that I'm
selling to people it doesn't cost me
anything and that's a great way I think
this is both for me it was like a a
useful tool but also I just want to
learn more about how to put things
together so I didn't you know plan this
in terms of I'm gonna make this app and
sell to a million people and everything
to start using it that's kind of a
different planning session oh hi okay
cool so I've only used DynamoDB once and
I found I was using it for really simple
things and the querying syntax was
actually low verbose there's a lot of
data type specifications and stuff and a
friend recommended well why don't you
just stick a bunch of Jason's and s3 and
just grab them by like filename
essentially using AZ index have you ever
tried something like that or happy I
haven't tried that but I love having
example sort at me so I can try
different thing so it's definitely a way
to do it I mean as you saw my workaround
was like okay what are other people
doing to define the data because I
realized the only thing I need to find
is the ID and that's where I use like
okay I stopped it at the API level
instead of stopping at the table level
but it's definitely a million
alternative solution so thank you for
your suggestion
all right anybody else okay
I'm gonna hang out a little while if you
think of something or just want to talk
one-on-one
[Applause]